let's say that we've got three bunnies
here and we're essentially adding up
their weight so each of these little
bunny pictures is represents the weight
of a bunny and we're told that that
equals the weight of these six objects
and these are literally one pound
weights
so one thing i want you to think about
is how can we represent what we just
drew here how can we represent it
algebraically and to give you a variable
to work with you could really say maybe
w for weight but i'll go with b so let's
say that let's let
the variable b
equal the weight
the weight
of
a
the weight of a bunny so if we use b is
the weight of a body how can we
represent this algebraically using this
variable
well there's actually a couple of ways
to do it you might say well look each of
these represents a b so i can literally
write it as b
plus b
plus b
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to these six pounds
and this is a valid representation but
it's not the simplest representation if
i add something like this if i have 3 of
something i literally could instead
write it as 3 times b so let me do it
that way so instead let me write it as 3
3b so this is essentially just another
way of representing these three b's
three b's or three times b
is equal to
is equal to
six
so how can we now solve for the weight
of a bunny and you might be able to do
in your head because we're essentially
saying 3 times the weight of a bunny is
equal to 6. but we're going to do it
logically so that you can later do much
much more hard to do in your head
problems
well if you have 3 times something and
you just want 1 times that something the
best thing to do might just be divide by
3. so if we divide by 3 right over here
3 times b divided by 3 well that's just
going to end up with a b
but we can't just divide the left hand
side then this equal side wouldn't hold
anymore we have to do the right hand
side as well so if we divide the right
hand side by 3 you get 6 divided by 3 or
we can rewrite this equation as b
is equal to b is equal to
2. and you can even think about it
visually up here what we did is we
divided both sides by 3. if you divide
this top left-hand side by 3 you get 3
groups of one bunny each or the weight
of one bunny each and on the right hand
side you divide it into three groups of
two pounds each so each bunny must weigh
two pounds each bunny the weight of a
bunny must be 2 pounds and i think you
saw what i did here i'm multiplying b
times 3 and then i divided by 3 to just
get a b over here but you might say hey
sal couldn't you instead have multiplied
both sides by 1 3 and then i would say u
yes that is absolutely true so let's go
back to this step right over here when
we had 3 times b
3 times b is equal to i'm making sure i
get the same colors
three times b is equal to six instead of
dividing by three we could have said hey
let's just multiply both sides by one
third and this is just i'm using our new
algebraic notation for multiplication
this is one third times three times b
this is six times one-third notice
multiplying by one-third is the exact
same thing as dividing by three and
that's all when you divide by three you
are multiplying by one-third
one-third times three is just going to
be equal to 1. so you're just left with
a b on the left hand side and on the
right hand side on the right hand side
you're left with a 6 times 1 3 which is
2. you're left with the exact the exact
same thing so the general idea here is
whatever we had multiplying by the b we
divided by that to solve for b or you
could say we multiplied we multiplied by
its reciprocal really just a fancy word
for one over that but either way we got
that each bunny is two pounds